first of all congratulations thank you
thank you obviously haley is in the show
and you had mentioned that you know once
you guys got engaged that it hit
different now that she was your fiance
you know it's a little different
yeah yeah you know
it's funny actually when we first
that there was a there was a time when i
introduced haley as my girlfriend and i
kind of stopped myself and i was like
this feels wrong i feel that that word
does not sort of live up to what this
relationship is and that was a good
indication of like okay i think it's
time to go to the next step so and not
only did you go to the next step but you
pulled off an epic surprise which i
didn't realize she was a tough one to
surprise impossible impossible that's
tough impossible so what's tougher then
pulling off this show in vegas or
pulling off a proposal to halo oh no
pulling off the proposal to haley it's
surprising here for sure was way more
difficult yeah yeah no that was like
some covert operations um which we're
actually making a little video right now
that we're gonna we're gonna post soon
showing how it all went down and stuff
i mean you had so much love and support
up in the comments a lot of famous
friends of course too but i saw even
jayla was like we have been waiting for
this derrick yes
yes i mean you had even jenny from the
block being like tick-tock no i mean i
remember seeing her and i was like yo if
she
if she can get two within the time that
i've been you know with her i better
step up my game right you know what i
mean no um
no it was it was awesome hearing from
everybody and the support and the love
and just you know
it it's great it's great it really is
beautiful it really is so let me ask you
this who do you think is going to make
it down the aisle first you and haley or
jen and ben
i'm i mean come on i don't know
who knows who knows you know what
double wedding i will just tell you this
i feel like their wedding will be a
little more expensive though i'm just
i'm just guessing
have you been on wedding planning at all
uh no no not yet not yet but um it's but
we want to get on it we don't want a
long engagement yeah yeah we've been
together long enough that's right yeah
and how involved will you be i bet you
have some ideas cooking up you know i
mean
like i'll be involved
but i but but i also like i also know
like this is something that is
also i trust the person we work with and
stuff and he's fantastic and
i i i will say this
i've already been booking talent oh
okay it's gonna be a festival i'm just
gonna tell you right now it's gonna be a
like a concert because we have some
really talented friends from towns and
friends and i'm like and i've actually
held them to i said hey before my
wedding you michael buble and he's like
yeah
so done listen jayla just did a movie
called marry me she's got a whole
soundtrack you know she's got some songs
on luck jay
you know she could pop out of a cake for
you i'm just saying actually will you
guys have like a special dance planned
you know it's funny people always say
that they're always like your wedding
dance is going to be off the hook and
i'm like honestly i don't i don't know
if we want to do a wedding day
maybe we'll do a little something side
to side but nothing elaborate because
you know we dance every day you want the
night off we were like yeah we're like
this is our night and you all perform
for us
it's like let's see what you have
planned i love it
[Music]
you